[Música]
[Aplausos]
comenzamos a seguir de cerca lo que
parecía un brote local por un nuevo
virus en la lejana ciudad dibujada en
china dos meses después más de 20
científicos voluntarios solo en nuestro
laboratorio dejamos de lado nuestras
investigaciones y nos involucramos 100%
a la generación de estrategias para
combatir este nuevo virus que ya se
había diseminado alrededor del mundo
en ciencia enfocada al estudio de los
microorganismos especialmente en
aquellos que nos causan daño no hay
cabida para una rutina monótona porque
tienes la oportunidad de plantearte
preguntas importantes en relación a
ellos y haciendo los experimentos
adecuadas puedes darles respuesta
para los curiosos finalmente esos somos
los científicos esto se convierte en una
atracción casi adictivo
en el transcurso del quehacer como
científico se comienzan a experimentar
situaciones que refuerzan nuestro
vínculo con la ciencia como es el
instante en el que solo tú y nadie más
conoce ese resultado importante antes de
comunicarlo al resto del mundo
responder preguntas en ciencias no es
tan sencillo como plantear las y hacer
experimentos sino que obedece a un
protocolo lo primero es tener una idea
generalmente tenemos muchos que no están
naturalmente luego cronograma hermano
planificamos con anticipación tiempos de
ejecución recursos humanos económicos
a la paz invertimos mucho mucho tiempo
en convencer a los entes evaluadores y
financiadores de que nuestra propuesta
es importante y relevante y que se
enmarca dentro de los temas prioritarios
en el país
y podría sernos de fondos y finalmente
desarrollar nuestra vida
como ven desde que se nos ocurre en una
pregunta hasta que podemos al menos
comenzar a responderla generalmente pasa
algún tiempo
sin embargo a veces las preguntas que
hay que responder amerita que nos
saltemos este proceso porque nos urge
desde nuestra curiosidad más que nos
llega impuesta por la vida como por
ejemplo que nos está matando nuestra
gente se está muriendo especial cada vez
más un panorama casi surrealista y nos
toca como generación científica de turno
responder la la pandemia de ccoo
víctimas
ante esta emergencia sanitaria todos
conocemos la maravillosa labor del
personal de salud de cara a cara con el
paciente pero que le corresponde hacer a
la ciencia a los científicos
principalmente conocer al enemigo para
poder atacar
debemos identificar quién es el agente
causal de dónde viene a quién se parece
que hace en nuestro organismo cómo muere
etc
en el contexto de una emergencia como
este que nos aquejan
abordar estas preguntas requiere
acelerar todo el protocolo científico es
decir no hubo una planificación previa
de por dónde comenzará no hay recursos
suficientes que podamos destinar a esta
situación y no el tiempo para conocer a
las autoridades de que es un tema
realmente importante que amerita todo su
apoyo
cada día que pasa enferman y mueren más
personas por lo que se hizo necesario
comenzar destinando todos los recursos
ya existentes en ciencia
lo más rápido y conveniente resultó unir
esfuerzos y recursos cada clientes de su
área de especialidad como resultado de
esta unión se logró determinar
rápidamente entre otras cosas que el
causante de la enfermedad era un nuevo
coronavirus
los coronarios que afectan a humanos se
conocen desde los años 70 relacionados
con resfriados e infecciones
respiratorias de heres pero el primero
con alta letalidad apareció en el año
2002 el virus causante del síndrome
respiratorio agudo severo y se denomina
osasco este 2 a cerca de 8 mil casos y
10 por ciento de mortalidad el segundo
en el año 2012 es el causante del
síndrome respiratorio de oriente medio o
médico el cual ha infectado cerca de
2.400 personas entre las que ha causado
un 30% de mortalidad
afortunadamente este virus no parece
propagarse bien entre humanos
luego de análisis genéticos se determinó
que lo que hoy nos azota era un nuevo
corona veloz que no había circulado
antes entre humanos el sars cop 2 y como
esta enfermedad fue descrita a finales
del año 2019 se le denominó coronaba
garros crisis del año 2000 1923
rápidamente se logró descifrar el genoma
del sar coptos la estructura de algunas
de las proteínas que lo conforman y
además que en moléculas participan en el
ingreso del virus a las células de
nuestro organismo
también se trabaja en entender cómo se
replica y el mecanismo por el cual causa
infecciones tan severas solo solo por
mencionar algunos aspectos
y para qué es necesario entender todos
estos aspectos
urgentemente los agentes curativos pero
también para poder pensar en una
estrategia de protección más definitiva
las vacunas
una de las preguntas más frecuentes es y
por qué tarda tanto el desarrollo de una
vacuna o cuánto tiempo falta
para aclarar esto es necesario entender
que el desarrollo de una vacuna es un
proceso complejo para empezar es
necesario conocer las características
biológicas del virus
a continuación se diseña la estrategia
para el candidato vacunal es decir
definir cómo sería la vacuna si basada
en virus inactivados atenuados moléculas
de adn adn o basada en componentes del
virus
posteriormente se desarrollan ensayos
que permitan evaluar su eficacia primero
en modelos animales y luego en un
pequeño grupo de voluntarios a dos para
posteriormente pasar a grupos más
grandes en los que se puedan probar
dosis y esquemas adecuados
si todo va bien se procede evaluar la
eficacia de la vacuna en un número aún
mayor de individuos
si los pasos anteriores han sido
exitosos hay que cumplir los requisitos
legales y regulatorios para su puesta en
circulación
todos estos pasos constituyen una
escalera que se puede subir más
rápidamente debido a la emergencia pero
no es posible omitir ningún escalón
porque si se hace estallar hemos en el
siguiente
conociendo a este proceso qué tan cerca
estamos de poder tener acceso a una
vacuna efectiva para el sarcoptes hay
muchos candidatos que prometen ser
exitosos provenientes de diferentes
países alrededor del mundo
pero que aún se encuentran en los
diferentes niveles de la escalera
los más cercanos ya están siendo
aprobados en pequeños grupos de
voluntarios sin embargo no será en menos
de pocos meses que podamos contar con
esta vacuna
el desarrollo de una vacuna en el
contexto de esta emergencia es un
proceso arduo que involucra la presión
de trabajar con la curva de la infección
cada vez pronunciándose con mayor
rapidez y viendo como la mortalidad se
eleva a medida que hervir que el virus
se disemina por el mundo
aunque se está trabajando a toda marcha
con la seguridad de que pronto tenemos
una solución permanente aún no la
tenemos miles de personas muertos y otro
tanto continúa muriendo cada día
está muy bien documentado que estudios
previos entre microorganismos similares
resultan fundamentales para lograr
avanzar rápidamente en la obtención de
una vacuna
por ejemplo en el año 2014 inicio el
peor brote del virus ébola en áfrica
occidental en el que el 90% de la
persona fallecía esta situación
representa un gran reto científico y
burocrático para poder lograr poner a
punto a una vacuna exitosa frente al
virus y se logró en ese momento
posteriormente en el 2018 ocurrió un re
brote de ébola el cual fue rápidamente
contenido y una de las claves para el
desenlace positivo de este rebrote con
la aplicación de las experiencias del
voto anterior y el contar con una vacuna
en el caso de los coronavirus otro sería
el escenario y mucho menos la
vulnerabilidad de nuestros sistemas si
luego de la circulación del también
letal se achicó en el año 2002 se
hubiese continuado con el financiamiento
al estudio de este virus
muy probablemente debido a las
similitudes entre la estructura y las
moléculas receptoras de los saps esto
hubiera aportado el camino a la
obtención de una actividad eficiente o
de una aguda
se han reportado una gran diversidad de
coronavirus en animales salvajes como
murciélagos pangolines y siberia desde
los que se sabe procede el cerco y se
presume pudo haber venido el sarcoptes
el consumo y tráfico de estos animales
salvajes obedece a hábitos culturales en
ciertas regiones que difícilmente
cambiarán en corto tiempo por
consiguiente el riesgo de introducciones
de nuevos virus de animales a humanos
continuará latente
estas situaciones pudieran anticiparse
con la monitorización constante de virus
en estos animales silvestres en
instalaciones de máxima seguridad pero
para controlar estos escenarios es
indispensable que el apoyo a la ciencia
por parte de los gobiernos sea constante
y no esperar a que las alarmantes curvas
epidemiológicas de infectados y
fallecidos serían las que marquen la
pauta para otorgar financiamientos de
forma casi expedita y con mínima
burocracia en los que prácticamente
comprometen a los científicos a la
generación de soluciones casi milagrosas
en cuestión de pocos meses
que nos está enseñando esta situación en
la ciencia
como científicos ante estos tan tercos
escenarios
tenemos la responsabilidad de
experimentar unificando esfuerzos no hay
tiempo para sobresalir individualmente
estamos viendo como científicos en
beijing o en bruselas comparten
voluntariamente material con científicos
en telecinco en cuernavaca
los laboratorios se han convertido en
pequeños campos de batalla desde donde
se fraguan las mejores estrategias para
combatir el saco
todos en ciencia queremos aportar
participando extrapolando experiencias
pasadas
y estamos aprendiendo corregir sobre la
marcha sin dejar de trabajar por lo que
anticipó que la edición final de
nuestros trabajos serán productos
verdaderamente valiosos
al resto de la población queremos
decirle que el esfuerzo que se está
haciendo desde las ciencias para generar
conocimientos redondearán soluciones
para combatir la cob en 19 estamos
optimistas de que pronto podemos contar
con una y mejor si varias vacunas
eficientes cuál será la vacuna más
eficiente pues de varias muy promisorias
desde que la aptitud entra esta vacuna
deja de ser relevante lo importante será
que sea segura y logre la protección
duradera de la población
no sabemos con exactitud cuándo
tendremos la vacuna pero sabemos que
estamos cada vez más cerca del final
mientras esto ocurre les pedimos
recurrir a fuentes confiables para
mantenerse correctamente informados
hay muchos aspectos que aún desconocemos
del virus pero les pedimos que nos
carguen en el desespero de seguir
soluciones charlatanas como ingerir
bicarbonato cloro vinagre que pueden
poner en riesgo su salud
les pedimos algo interactuar
directamente con personas aparentemente
sanas o ya recuperadas de la infección
sin la protección adecuada queremos
recordarles que un alto porcentaje de
las personas infectadas puede ser
asintomática durante todo el curso de la
infección o estar en el periodo
sintomático de la enfermedad el cual
puede llegar a ser hasta de 14 días en
ambos casos estas personas son
transmisores del virus
por otra parte ha pasado poco tiempo
para conocer cuán robusta y duradera es
la respuesta es monetaria protectora que
genera en los pacientes ya recuperados
por lo que ellos también deben guardar
las medidas de protección
este virus no solo no va a desaparecer
al menos en el corto plazo sino que
puede mutar y no podemos predecir si
para atenuarse o no es muy pronto no lo
conocemos
la probabilidad de que surjan otros
virus con potencial pandémico sigue
estando en tradicionalmente
por consiguiente hablar de una nueva
realidad con nuevos ámbitos sociales en
cuanto todo esto se verá más controlado
debe ser concebido como un asunto
obligatorio
las epidemias vienen y se van
la pregunta es con qué necesitamos
quedarnos cuando esta pandemia pasó
definitivamente y así tengamos una
solución permanente como sociedad
tenemos el deber de incorporar nuestros
nuevos hábitos especialmente de higiene
y desechar definitivamente otros como el
consumo de tráfico de animales salvajes
como una nueva forma de vida
si la abrazó el filósofo inglés thomas
hobbes el conocimiento es poder la
resultar cierto entonces aprender a
incorporar las nuevas medidas sociales
para prevenir situaciones futuras
similares definitivamente será el
superpoder que nos dejará hasta atrás
muchas gracias